simple yetis  these positions  and now after AC look F6 it's winning  again I mean okay just how do you  understand what's going on because I  remember very clearly of course from the  tie break between Carlson and Karana in  world championship match here they also  had it was hng but it was the same  concept yeah ah but hang on there there  was a chance to play Rook G1 check I  think  this is the key motive that is  seven yeah exactly I think that's the  key asking if you give a check on I give  a check exactly  because I thought I would have Rook F6  checking cameras no and and then look  just look G6 and then the look Gets  behind  that that was the reason why King G4 was  such a big mistake  that's it because yeah usually I thought  like I mean my feeling was just King G2  and uh put the look behind and then I  mean also put it immediately maybe yeah  yeah but after this